on entend souvent dire que les tomates
coûte plus rien parce qu on est
nostalgique où c'est vrai que les
tomates sont moins bonnes qu'avant
vous êtes souvent des tomates tueuses
comme moi j'appelle ça la met debout
pour mes préférés toutefois grand chose
aux gens la chance à votre lot plus que
d'autre chose savaient pas ta mère ces
crises du caire charles gaulle elle a
déjà entendu dans les champs
l'université laval
il mène des recherches pour améliorer la
saveur des tomates
son équipe et lui cultive mille cinq
cents variétés qui sont toutes issues de
croisements génétiques
[Musique]
non
où
la pouvoir des gens sont très contents
qu'on travaille sur la route d'un tomate
parce que c'est un produit qui est
reconnu comme état plutôt faire d'un
extrait que tout le monde est déjà goûté
en jardin d'excellents thomas qui en
termes d'arôme oussedik web amélioré
mais la plupart des tomates commerciales
ont été sélectionnés davantage pour
détester à gros nez
beaucoup moins pour les armes parce que
c'est extrêmement complexe
la fin s'est pas fait du tout du tout
sur la route donc il ya vraiment un gros
retard est rattrapé à ce niveau la quête
d'une tomate plus goûteuse se poursuit
en laboratoire le chercheur et son
équipe
extrait les composés volatils du fruit
lors d'une analyse par chromatographie
ce procédé consciente les arômes qui
seront ensuite analysées combien
d'arômes vous êtes ce type de récolter à
travers ça une soixantaine d'euros
ferran avait composé qui ont des arômes
les audard totalement différente comme
le whisky comme la framboise comme bien
des fleurs ou même comme le gaz ont
couru la sélection des jeunes reliés aux
arômes en question permet ensuite aux
chercheurs de développer de nouvelles
saveurs
on a un type de tomates qu'on appelle
les tomates banane qui ont énormément
d'esther c'est pas des composés volatils
dans le bacon delà de façon abondante
dans l'atome
on a aussi par croisement à obtenir des
variétés qui en produisent beaucoup plus
et qui donne un arôme de bonbons à la
banane artificielle donc ajouté abu
thomas de bananes
ça coûte vraiment beaucoup la balance de
surprenant ça c'est super on va en film
est plein
donc je reviens pas ont créé les tomates
dahmane pourrait un jour se retrouver au
supermarché
mais pour ça il faudra qu'ils compagnie
s'intéresse à ce type de produits pour
l'instant les multinationales qui
détermine quels tomates nous mangeons tu
sélectionnes surtout des lignes réputées
pour leurs capacités de conservation car
les tomates voyage souvent sur de
longues distances
36% des tomates oeufs consommés au pays
proviennent du mexique il 6% des états
unis d'ailleurs dans les années 70 les
agriculteurs américains en fait appel à
des ingénieurs
il voulait savoir quel poids les tomates
pouvait supporter quand on les empilées
les unes sur les autres dans des camions
de nos jours les grandes compagnies qui
offrent des semences aux producteurs du
monde entier font la promotion de la
durabilité et de la résistance aux
maladies
elle parle aussi d'uniformité de
potentiel de rendement mais plus
rarement du goût
on s'en va rencontrer le deuxième plus
important producteur de tomates de serre
de la province
pour lui toute cette histoire de perte
de saveurs et d'arômes street
n'empêche pas d'accord du tout fou mais
encore une fois c'est très subjectif et
c'est le souvenir de passer s'améliore
avec les années je pense 6000 tonnes de
tomates sont produites ici chaque année
dans d'immenses air qui s'étendent sur
10 hectares on y cultive six variétés
c'est possible de choisir une variété
qui ont un goût qui vraiment le critère
numéro un qui tout le monde dort un
accord sur le goût mais il est possible
aussi que ça se fasse au détriment du
coût de production
si par exemple j'ai un produit qui coûte
25 % plus cher à produire mais que j'ai
un super goût parfait de ce qu'on veut
au maximum pour choix capable de
transférer cette charge supplémentaire
vers les consommateurs et que eux se
croient capables de l'apprécier c'est le
code certaines tomates de spécialités
comme la bella mais c'est l'exception
parmi les cultivent est revendue par
demers aux principales bannières
d'alimentation de la province au
quotidien avec nos clients
on parle de volume on parle de maturité
est un fruit qui est prêt à être vendu
dans les 24 prochaines heures ou si un
petit peu de délai avant campus de
travail et donc c'est surtout de ceux
dont on parle et de prix bien entendu
aujourd'hui en novembre et de récolte
s'est produit deux sont emballés la
journée même sont placés dans notre
frigo la journée même à l'occasion va
partir le jour même ou le lendemain ici
les tomates ne sont jamais réfrigéré à
moins de 12 degrés celsius la
température minimale pour garder la
saveur d'une tomate mais c'est en
sortant nécessaire que les choses
peuvent se vanter dans quel contexte
pour arriver vos tomates finesse à être
à 4 degrés très peu là je vous dirai
peut-être dans des situations de poules
de camions de camionnage
donc s'il faut mettre les pommes et les
bananes et aussi des tomates bien
l'yonne nécessairement une température
qui est combiné c'est difficile à
contrôler pour nous le réseau de
distribution il est l'heure pour une
raison économique aussi et d'efficacité
de transport donc ça fait partie de deux
de l'histoire sont pesées et un
producteur de tomates de serre à
drummondville qui pense avoir trouvé la
solution pour pas altérer le goût de ses
tomates on va aller voir comment il s'y
prend
[Musique]
vous très important c'est comme ma
marque de commerce sa voix d afrique
goûte bon truc il ya une beaucoup
question transports quelqu'un qu'il faut
que cet amateur du mexique
ces emprunts comme animal de brisbane
des tomates vertes moins de déchets par
terre puis à se brisera même paul ne
peut pas tout avoir dans la vie tu peux
avoir des balles de baseball par
vendetta bateau bon goût les deux vont
pas lui qui verriez cultive 68 tonnes de
tomates par année on peut dire que c'est
une culture artisanale
souvent je vois sacrifier leur en main
pour le mou jamais envoyé moins drame
ait pu être capable de jeu capable de
vendre est un petit peu plus cher à
cause de ces accords les amateurs en bas
là c'est moi qui les visent notamment
l'épicerie les rangs du love c'est moi
qui m'a reçue qu'il prenne pop qui
émettent au frigo les mutuelles ça soit
dans le bac store à 20 degrés que dans
le frigo à 4 mais la solution de luxe
verrier n'est pas à la portée de tous
c'est thomas de voyage tout au plus à
montréal sinon elles sont distribués
dans certaines épiceries de
drummondville gros morne
quand on les a pas il les recherches et
il et damman pour eux c'est
irremplaçable et les tomates le secret
c'est pas trop d'acidité il va vraiment
dans le coup et plus sucré surtout pour
les rouges la tomate rouge vous dirais
que ce mal est excellente aussi qu'est
ce que vous auriez à dire aux
consommateurs qui recherchent des
tomates qui ont dû vous achetez des
producteurs locaux pour lui un sacré
donc j'ai dit on arrive juste devant la
variété que je préfère dans chat tomates
vertes est super intéressante que ça
fait sept ans qu'on travaille dessus
qu'on goûte on goûte
c'est vrai que c'est très bon pour
charles goulet on n'en est qu'aux
balbutiements de la dégustation de
tomates
il espère qu'un jour les québécois qui
connaîtront assez pour faire la
distinction entre plusieurs variétés
moi ce que j'aimerais voir
éventuellement dans les lycées c'est
vraiment une identification de parenté
comme on voit avec la banque pour que le
consommateur puisse choisir qu'est ce
qu'elle est retournée météo pour
vraiment voir produits peuvent être plus
plu définit plus rapide plus intéressant
donc c'est pas un mythe
plusieurs variétés de tomates ont perdu
du bus fil des ans et la mondialisation
l'industrie les consommateurs ont leur
part de responsabilité mais on sent que
les choses changent et qu'il ya un
appétit pour les tomates de spécialités
est un match sans saveur son peut pas
être sur leurs derniers milles